people think of physicists as all the
same you know first of all Brian Greene
or Jen 11. what is the primary
distinction in your mind of an
experimental physicist what can he or
she most uniquely contribute to the
Public's understanding of science we're
to create that dichotomy between
theorists and experimentalists some
people do both but an experimental
physicist rather than just looking at
the mathematics and the mathematical
Concepts and trying to create a theory
from which something can be predicted
their job I sort of say is much more
nuanced so they have to keep in mind and
understand the mathematics and the
theory and work with it but they also
have to be able to look Beyond it and to
look for things that maybe nobody has
ever thought about before and nobody has
predicted